this is perfect at the two-year here
together because I didn't big question
about that the speech like a pre battle
pre-war speech and if film like this a
lot of people expect it they know it
what kind of pressure is there to to get
that speech trying to make it hit and
for you to perform it so that it is
something that people will remember well
I feel you know that's almost almost
like that's the anti-war speech and
certainly it's the both in volume and
and you know
rattling up the troops hopefully don't
know and it's member it rings true but
it's the anti speech in that how doesn't
necessarily believe an initiative of why
they're all there the nationalistic
streak that you find in the speech he
also perhaps finds in doubt he's younger
than what the circumstance normally
would be if someone giving that kind of
speech so I think there's a lot of you
know there's a lot of mechanisms within
the speech that are playing against it
or at least in a circumstance mmm yeah
it's daunting you know because I mean
it's you've seen that kind of moment in
lots of movies where just you know the
rallying speech before the battle and
it's like you know when the one hand is
daunting because you got God here we go
it's another one of these but also
knowing that precedent had been set by
Shakespeare and the you know it's one of
the great speeches in English literature
and it's what what can what I mean and
you know without learning to give
anything away I feel like I've we found
beautiful ways of having calculated to
of getting to do it but approach it from
a different angle and and that that was
liberating in the writing yeah I
couldn't help but thinking while I was
watching the movie and especially during
that speech about young people today
making a point to overthrow a generation
before them I am talking about like yeah
right now with climate change on you do
you see the parallel when you look at
the film now yeah absolutely I mean I
think it's a great way to put it and I
think you could even I guess in our
generation especially as relates to the
climate crisis just by way of age we
haven't had anybody that's sixteen
seventeen is sent to these positions of
power yet yeah although we have people
like Greta or who are you know in
and I don't see any publicity but who we
you know making noise yet making noise
hey we see a lot of but the I I think
there's maybe a parallel here I want you
Tessa mystic or cynical or something
where a young person steps into a
position of power with very good intent
and honor and creating pre-existing
institutions of power that are you know
that stand across human history to
reinforce status quo today that would be
destroying the earth and then it would
have been keeping you know different
families and in power that those those
institutions can be overwhelming it too
strongly sometimes yeah I want to talk
about Robert and his his portrayal in
this movie he is like he really goes for
it you know it was like working with him
and and as a follow up we know things
going Batman do you think you'd want to
work with him in that scenario as well
it was real honor to work with Robert I
mean I grew up with his uh I grew up
with him as like the you know young male
actor you know in the big movies like
Twilight but also in really great you
know smaller movies like the rover they
did with David and yeah and especially
last couple years he's done like
extraordinary work so a big honor and uh
and we'll say yeah maybe it'll be
something else that I can get to work
with alone maybe we can yeah yeah but no
it's fun you know I just I cast Rob
really early he agreed to do it really
early when we work Jolin on writing
because I just knew he would have fun
with that character yeah I just wanted
him to go nuts yeah